we um we don't need to
go through the the chairman's
unmemorized
speech and um
while we are waiting for the
mickey has prepared an amendment
um
um one zero two
seven i did you send that to everyone
mickey or not
everybody should have it and it is on
the website now too
okay okay so um
mickey do you want to go through and
explain what this does and
what it will cause us to do sure so the
two amendments that we
approved earlier today had transfers
between the education trust fund and the
general fund included so
if you recall the first one that we had
done that had the
dot transfers and excuse me the dot
thank you
um uh andrea dot and school building aid
in there there was a transfer over the
biennium of 36.7 million dollars out of
the education trust fund to fund
some things the second amendment that we
adopted this morning had a
100 million dollar swing of money going
the other way
so it was suggested that rather than
having
36.7 going one way and a hundred million
dollars going
the other way we just do the net of that
which is 63.3 going one way
so what the committee could do is if you
wanted to adopt this amendment
i would modify those previously approved
amendments to take out
the transfers so we don't have multiple
transfers happening we can just do it
one time
so there's no net impact of this motion
it's just uh
instead of two swings of money we're
just going to do one to kind of clean up
house bill 2 as well as the surplus
statement
anyone have any thoughts madam chair
yes please go ahead um
my question is so this means that we
will
not take money out of the education
trust
will simply reduce the amount of money
coming into the education trust
right and so it keeps it clean that way
and accomplishes um not taking money out
of the trust to be used for d.o.t
yeah those appropriations for dot will
still occur from the general fund
it's just there's going to be no money
exiting the education trust fund
yes thank you that's what i was hoping
it would do thank you
are there any other questions comments
yeah i think i'm i think i'm okay with
that i wanted to
um i understand all these amendments
because i'm here but i was worried
going forward if people are trying to
reconstruct things going backwards that
that might be confusing
but um the way representative heath just
posed her question um to mickey
it seems like it is actually less
confusing
and i like that it doesn't make this
it doesn't we're not looking at taking
money from education
out of the trust fund which is you know
for a lot of people a very very
uncomfortable thing to do
so this is putting in basically less
money into the education trust fund that
we're going to use
and the transportation money comes out
of general fund
so i'm just is that i think i'm
repeating what representative heath said
i wanted to make sure that that's kind
of what it means
that's a correct understanding and as
far as trying to track
all the work we're doing um i'm gonna do
something once we officially close our
business on house bill one and two
that'll make it
clear for the committee and the public
we'll put it online as far as
what the division ultimately has
recommended
for amendments and changes to the budget
that you'll be bringing to the full
committee
it's not uncommon that we adopt
amendments and then reconsider
them and you know whether it's on a zoom
or in a committee meeting sometimes it's
hard to keep track of everything but
certainly when we're done our business i
will make it clear as to
you know what we've got in our plan to
bring to the full committee
i'm very supportive of it you have not
you know
um i guess realistically or not taking
money out of the education trust fund
but just
okay are there any other
okay seeing none could i have
a motion to approve
amendment 1027h
and just to modify or expand on the
motion
it's also to you know in place of those
transfer sections in the previously
approved just so that's clear for
everybody
as discussed okay all right
uh representative petrie made the motion
do i have a second
representative lin are you in the mood
to call the role or are you striking
no i'm not i'm in the mood thank you
all right representative petra
richard moussies representative bucca
jucco votes yes representative heath
heath vote yes and thank you very much
madam chair
uh representative uh murder
representatives
representative lynn votes yes um
representative murray
murray votes yes and representative
umberger
representative umberger vote chess all
right it's a vote of seven to zero in
the affirmative
timeshare okay thank you
um mickey
i just saw the amendment
from representative ladd yeah
so the amendment that he just sent i can
share that language with us but that is
an amendment to senate bill 135 not to
house bill two so we can't really use it
for
but we can look at the language and you
know while the house bill two amendment
is being drafted you can at least have
the discussion
okay so if you'd like i can uh i can
bring that up
and we can do you want to bring that
bring that up in as well or
we'll bring mark in or mark excuse me
hi mark hello good afternoon
let me bear with you perhaps you could
uh kind of walk us through
what this does um
why it's uh something that appears to be
necessary
you could um so when the governor was
modeling out adequacy as well as um all
the fiscal notes we've been providing
we've been under the assumption that we
are hoping for a
normal spring assessment so spring
assessment is
that we'll be doing the third grade
reading assessment testing for third
grade reading proficiency
and those numbers um depending on how
people score how kids score
gets rolled into a differential aid
category called the third grade reading
differential aid category
um so we've been assuming that for 2021
the spring of 20 the spring we're in
right now
we'll have normal assessment numbers but
now we're starting to have doubts that
we'll have
wide participation in our schools with a
assessment
so those numbers that we provided that
the governor has
put in his model for adequacy and the
numbers we've been providing to mickey
are assuming are based on 2019
assessment data
so what the amendment i sent to to you
and
mickey
[Music]
has us look at 2019 data
and have us look at 2021 data and pick
the better data set
so what it would do is completely match
how
the governor has built adequacy and
completely match how all the formulas
all the adequacy spreadsheets you've
been looking at um
it would were based on the assumption
that 2020 assessment data would match
so all this amendment does is um we will
look at 2019 assessment data and we look
at 2021 assessment data and pick the
greater of the two data sets
so it's not predicted to have any impact
yeah i'm sorry representative rosen
murray
thank you i'm not sure when we've got
these little pictures what you can
actually see
can you explain why it wouldn't have an
effect on the budget because
it it um you know there's going to be a
difference in the numbers
um in the adma and why wouldn't that
have an effect on the budget
thank you yeah so um it will um impact
the numbers certainly
but when the governor was building his
budget he assumed
um in that 900 some odd million that you
have in front of you
um he assumed assessment would be around
the um 2019 levels and so he's
so all we're doing is is making sure
that assumption
takes place um because we'll probably
have really
low participation in the assessments in
2021 which will pay the state fiscal
year 2022 adequacy
so for budgeting purposes this will have
no
impact because it would be essentially
using the same numbers that have already
built into your assumption
that we'll have a clean assessment in
um so have no it's just it's just having
the law
match the assumptions essentially thank
you
representative heath so thank you madam
chair so
um this actually
um
fixes the enrollment issue
that um but this piece of it is only
specific
to that that category itself
it does not cross categories
so we would only be using the enrollment
data for this one purpose or will this
cover all purposes will this fix the
problem
that school districts across the state
are going through right now
so representative heath what you're
looking at is senate bill 135
which covers all of the all of the adma
components
um like you just said um so that covers
your your regular enrollment fnr
third grade reading special education
that's what senate bill 135 does
if you were just looking to fix the
third grade issue
third grade reading assessment data
that's the amendment i've
i've passed on to representative
umberger
but but yeah the this one would deal
with all the adma components but i've
drafted a
draft language to fix just the third
if i may yeah certainly
so this then will not um
apply to the overall
adequacy only to this reading
issue yep the amendment that's ols is
currently working on would only apply to
the third grade reading component that's
correct
madam chair can i ask another question
yes you may
so um that we know that school districts
across the state have seen
big drops manchester has seen
at least six to seven hundred nashua six
to seven hundred
and that pretty much parlays pretty much
with freedom-reduced
lunch as well so
this amendment will not relate to those
numbers or will it
um it's tricky the amendment in front of
you that's on the screen
would would would do what you would do
what you're saying would relate to all
those numbers
but the amendment that ols is drafting
would would not
cover base enrollment and all the other
components all right
thank you yeah representative i think
that
135 covers all those things that you're
talking about
but this amendment is specific to
third grade reading period and that yeah
and that they're asking
for this amendment to
make sure that what's calculated
in our formula matches what the law
is and right now it does not
so to better clarify the amendment that
ols is working on right now
really syncs up to if you look at line
six um
line six to line 11. that would just
deal with the third grade reading
essentially that would just deal with
you're a follow-up representative i do
thank you madam chair
so again um this will not solve the
problem the districts are having
overall this will just address one piece
this this will not fund if they're
suffering loss and enrollments this will
not um
this will not give them extra money for
are there any other questions
okay so when this amendment
gets back from ols
is there anyone that will have a problem
okay i don't see that so
close this out mary did you have another
question or
nope you're still muted sorry my screen
moved over and i couldn't see the mute
button
we support that section of it but i'm
also concerned that it doesn't fix
the bigger issue that school districts
have across the state
and um sb 135 addresses some of it but
not all of it
so um yes we support the section but um
we'd like to see more i certainly
understand that
representative heath and i think that's
what uh
your amendment is trying to address
right now
right now okay we need to fix
the um third grade reading scores
or whatever third grade people
scoring below proficient and um
i have no idea when uh
when they'll have the tests to make sure
to figure that out
so okay um i understand
mickey has sent
the amendment that you have
proposed or are proposing
yeah amendment uh 1028h
representative heath's amendment um
should was this email to everybody
and we've got it online too if it's not
already there it'll be refreshed shortly
so
the public can find it there too so we
can share that screen
as well um i may see if andrea is
available to do that
well she looks like a stick figure but
i assume that means she's there
i am here madam chair and it is actually
online i will bring it up right on the
screen for you right now
it's up on the screen now if everyone
can see it okay
uh representative heath you want to walk
through this
for us i'd be happy to and then um i'm
sure mickey will
help me if i um if i'm inaccurate on any
point
so basically what this amendment says
it appropriates the hundred million
dollars
for the fiscal year ending 23
to the education trust and i'm going to
just move down to number two
where it says for fiscal years 2022-23
the total education
grant to each municipality pursuant to
rsa 198 colon 41
shall be adjusted to an amount no less
than
such grant in prior years
which takes care of the issue around
enrollment
however total adjustments for the
biennium ending june 30th
2023 uh shall not exceed 100 million
dollars
unless pursuant to paragraph three
the department of education shall
prorate adjustments as necessary
so what um section three does
any unspent surplus balance in the
education
trust fund as of june 30th 2023
shall be applied to increase the hundred
dollar
100 million dollar cap on the total
education grant
so basically this is like a waterfall
effect
then those funds would be applied
and correct me if i'm wrong mickey these
funds would be applied
to the allocations in districts now i
just want to use i'm going to use
farmington because that's um a district
where representative petry comes from
and if you look at the chart
that was sent to you
this morning by um mickey you'll see
that what farmington would receive
under house bill 623 and then
under 135 so the amount
for farmington it's it's over a million
dollars
it would be pro-rated uh based on the
amount of money we have because now it's
only a hundred million dollars
and so without any of this farmington
only gets about 200
000 and i don't have the chart in front
of me so i'm just
doing estimates so the
each school district will effectively
get more funding based on
the allocations that we sent out
um in the last biennium but i think the
advantages
of this the proposal um
[Music]
the previous proposal that we have it
really
it reduces statewide property taxes
by a certain percentage
but in fact those communities
that have been most hit with
the impact of kobit and that it's
more difficult from for them to raise
property taxes
what will happen is we're going to see
maybe on one side
something's going to go down but then on
the local property taxes
we're going to see an increase so i
think all in all
the districts that need the bigger
benefit that's
offered through this amendment will win
and with the other amendment everybody
gets a reduction
but many will end up seeing a
significant increase in their property
taxes
based on the fact that there will not be
a higher level of adequacy funding for
those districts
i think i've covered everything mickey
i think that i think that covers what
this amendment does
so i ask for your support for this
amendment
it's um it's an amendment
it does it fixes the enrollment numbers
it it adds to the amount of money going
to school districts
effectively this will result
in a a more proportional a more
proportionate
reduction i know well in property taxes
than than what the initial proposal will
do
and you know it's just the more affluent
school districts are going to make out
on this
and the poorer school districts like
farmington like berlin like manchester
um nashua so many of these districts
that
have so felt the impact
of of the pandemic won't
feel the benefits that this amendment
will offer
so i ask for your support thank you very
much
representative murray thank you
yeah i had a couple things um one what
appeals to me about this in particular
that this is education trust
fund money that is going directly to
education
as opposed to kind of taking a backward
spin towards the swept funds it also
provides the municipalities the
opportunity
if it suits what they want to do to make
their own decisions about how to manage
the sweat funds
i was trying to do some math very
quickly and i probably did not do it
well i was looking up the numbers of
farmington since
um representative heath brought that up
and quickly and i could be wrong so i'm
a little anxious about this
but um it's a it's a significant amount
of money
that farmington would get going this
route as opposed to
sort of the difference between you know
everybody in town getting twenty dollars
um to do whatever they want with as
opposed to
aggregating all that money and putting
all that money towards
directly towards education so i do like
that this is education money that is
directed
immediately towards education as opposed
to
another program so that's my comments
is there anyone else that has a comment
okay i don't see any hands hands raised
where it says shall be
adjusted to amount
no less than such grant in the prior
year
so this is taking it back
to 21
even though the money that was provided
in
21 from the um
adequacy was a number i don't have in
front of me
but that is the number that you would be
working from because that's what that
says
i'm just getting my book
i just wanted to see what uh what was
um mickey maybe you know the answer
as opposed to me unless you're um
yeah so so are you looking for the total
estimated
uh essentially what the level would be
compared to no less than like that what
the amount was in 21 essentially
yes so it's about uh 1 billion
13 million is the number that we've got
for that
but is that just adequacy or is that
adequacy plus that's the total education
grant so that includes
adequacy stabilization swept that's
retained locally everything
right but is it that that figure
is the 62 000
million plus is that correct yeah that
that 62 million was part of that so that
one time
fiscal capacity disparity aid and
additional aid on free reduced lunches
part of that billion dollar number two
okay so that 62 million dollars would
have to come out of here
because that was not provided in
adequacy
it was provided someplace else it's not
in the
cost of an adequate education but it was
in the calculation of a total education
grant so the intent of this amendment is
to include everything
including that additional 62.5 million
i don't understand that i'm sorry so
for the purposes of this amendment and
the term total education grant
refers to the cost of adequacy
right as well as any swept that's
raised and retained locally any
stabilization grant
or in the case of fiscal 21 those
one-time additional aid components of
capacity disparity and free reduced
lunch enhanced so
so when we talk total education grant in
the terms of fiscal 21 it includes all
of those components
and it's around just over a billion
dollars
in in the budget before you now and we
haven't touched this line
it's 933 million in fiscal 22 and 946
million
this is attempting to make up for
the 1.024 billion is that correct
uh the the true amount ended up being
1.013 billion but yes
that was how much was well that's how
much was budgeted but the actual ended
up being more like 1.013
billion
so that's 54
and 60 right
uh i think it's the numbers i got here
are 74 and 67
first 22 and 23. so that's the
about 141 million dollars over the
biennium we were
talking about this morning however this
amendment
provides only 100 million dollars of
that estimate
therefore the proration provision okay
[Music]
again my concern
as i spoke earlier about the other
amendment
is that um the
uh the school districts will
expect this amount of money no matter
what happens
and that is my concern
if adm goes down
then it doesn't matter because
you're saying in here that the number of
children don't matter
the number of free and reduced lunch
doesn't matter
nothing matters they're going to get
this no matter what and
that is a total and complete
change to how we do
education funding it reminds me
of the stabilization grant
where we pay we're still paying school
districts
for stabilization
and what this reminds me of
is that's exactly what
the way this bill is worded and what i
understand
uh would occur and
i don't think in my mind
that um we can
continue to pay schools
for children that don't exist
and um that that's
that's one of my very major concerns
about this uh this legislation
so i see i've got two hands raised and i
mickey does it tell me here someplace uh
representative heath and representative
murray have their hands raised oh okay
that's fine
uh representative heath were you first
yes thank you thank you
you know i agree with you completely
however um
right now we're in a time unlike
uh any other um unlike any other
we are in a biennium and this
would affect am i correct mickey it only
would impact
this biennium because then at thereafter
it's going to go back to the ama count
that's how enrollments are fixed but
remember we have a year lag
so what school districts they got their
their funding but then the following
year when you project out they're going
to be
hit with this um completely
um odd enrollment number that that
doesn't really reflect what happened and
it is directly due to covid
so i just i really think it's a win-win
situation
with this amendment um everybody wins
this way
and it helps to fix a problem that has
erupted as a direct result of covet
thank you madam chair
representative murray thank you um
your point around the enrollment is you
know
spot on is there and mickey maybe can
help us out
is there a way to adjust the language
here
to reflect the concern that this you
know going forward how it is done
it is based on the ada um
and you know i see where
one could read this of it not being
there i also take representative heath's
point and now
this was such a one-off year i mean you
know with the covet
hardly any all the numbers are kind of
spurious
so is there a way to address
representative umberger's concern
that you know in the end this needs to
reflect
um actual enrollments you know is there
can we can we work around can we work
i mean current law is is essentially a
per capita formula so if
i mean not doing anything is essentially
paying the formula based on the kids
at the schools um the idea with a couple
of the pieces of legislation
from the senate were to use the
adm counts from the year prior to the
pandemic
to calculate grants house bill 623 took
a different approach and just said
don't even artificially recalculate the
uh student counts just determine
is this grant calculated gonna be less
than what you got last year and then
just bring everybody up to what they got
the year before
so there are a few different legislative
proposals
to manipulate ed funding for 22 and 23
to do just to make the payments be
directly
to how many students are in the counts
but the governor the governor used
[Music]
the free and reduced lunch from
19. uh the governor so what's in house
bill 2 that we've already accepted to
stay in house bill 2
is an adjustment to the free reduced
lunch counts based on their portion of
our proportion of free reduced lunch
kids the year before so yes there is
in the budget already that we've uh in
sections 45 and 46
approved an adjustment to the free and
reduced lunch adm
so that that is in there now yes okay
i know that uh and i again this is
we talked about this earlier and that is
expectations and
i am very concerned
just like this year i can't tell you the
number of emails that i received
that uh they're polite
but uh basically saying i want my 90
and so instead of 90 million
they're now going to want 90 million
plus 100 million
to make up for what they believe they
have lost
and i guess that the other thing
from my perspective anyhow is
that according to doe
there are really no strings attached
what's
i shouldn't say whatsoever but they're
very few strings attached
to the 350 billion that's going to be
distributed to the schools i guess 320
is going to actually be distributed to
the schools so
i just am i just am not in favor
of of creating
knowing that the money that they will be
getting
from doe to spend
can be spent any way
that it needs to be and so
i am just i just
i thank you and i and i understand your
passion okay
i mean i do uh but
um i just think that
um this is this is not the
right way to spend this money
because with the
with the other amendment um
we're actually uh reducing
[Music]
taxes and this i'm afraid
as we went on would not accomplish
that same thing because it seems
every time we have provided money
to the uh school systems
instead of taxes going down
taxes have gone off you know i mean
there are all kinds of reasons why taxes
go up i won't
i won't uh argue that but um
anyhow uh representative heath thank you
madam chair
so just let me talk to that a little bit
um school districts whoops
school districts will be receiving
federal dollars that's
absolutely true but those federal
dollars
are adequacy goes out to school
districts
directly that goes right to the
municipality
so they have that money with the federal
dollars that are coming in
they do not go directly to the school
district
they are provided to the school district
on a reimbursement
methodology based on a plan that the
school district
sends to the department of ed so for
example
manchester um in the first part of money
they got 6.7 million dollars and
they haven't spent that much of it yet
because
they have just they decided to use a
huge
portion of that money to buy equipment
and there was a drag
on the equipment order it it's taken a
lot longer because everybody needs um
new computers and and
new technology equipment right now so
the city of manchester can't say we need
this money now
they have to wait until they spend those
dollars
and then ask for reimbursement for those
dollars so that kind of creates this
double whammy
so when some school districts are
getting these funds
their local school district financial
situation
is such that if they go out and spend
let's say
two or three million dollars they have
to spend it first
and then that creates a fiscal issue
right there and then
that it takes at least a month for the
department of ed
to reimburse the school district for
those dollars that they expended those
federal dollars
so you've got a a cycle going on
what we're looking at now by doing this
amendment
we'd be directing dollars directly to
school districts
over which they don't have to make a
purchase first they have available to
them right away
the federal dollars don't work like that
my point um is that why i feel that this
amendment
assists them in this arena thank you
madam chair
uh representative heath i know that
you've mentioned a couple times the
computers at
uh in manchester do you have any idea
how much
uh is tied up in that oh it's about two
million dollars
okay and so the other four is what
um i i haven't checked that was quite a
while ago
we had met with the commissioner and
caitlyn um
to look at that part of money and then
to look at the
next um uh amount of money that was
coming into the city and
and so it's been a while so i don't know
what they have drawn down at this point
in time
sorry i don't know the um i don't know
the issue that's going on with
manchester
u is it um you're looking for that four
million dollars
well what what um representative heath
said is that they had obligated about
2 million for computers
and that they had received 6 million
and so i was wondering what they are
doing with the other
four million has it been spent
has it not been spent have the computers
come in
yeah i can look into that
but adam chair i mean i i'm just
all i'm you know i all i'm saying is is
that
i i understand how education
funding works in in federal grants
and um it's uh
i don't like it okay i would much rather
have
doe pay the bill and not uh
not have to go through the not have to
go through the regular role that
uh that that they do but unfortunately
i think that's how the education federal
grants work
so maybe you could work on that mary is
getting the
getting uh the education department to
change that but
um anyhow okay um
does anyone else have anything they'd
like to say
oh representative heath um madam chair
thank you
i just i'd like to move the motion i
think
that um move the amendment and i just
um think that this point in time this is
something we need to do
and in the long run we'll go back to the
regular
what the law says um in terms of the adm
a count um but i do think this step
is a better step for us to take with
that 100 million dollars
rather than to reduce the
school-wide property tax um for each
community
i just think the bigger bang is going to
come from the hundred thousand
going directly to school districts thank
you madam chair
and i would ask one of my colleagues or
someone to make a second to this motion
uh okay
this is amendment 1028h
uh represent lynn when you're ready to
myrna votes no uh representative lynn
votes no
uh representative murray murray vos yes
and representative umberger votes no uh
madam chair the vote is four to three uh
in the negative
okay so the uh
the amendment fails okay
uh representative heath did you have
i do comment let's say thank you for
allowing us um
the time to be able to come forward with
this amendment thank you very much
well i i feel you know i feel very
honestly if this amendment had come in
a week ago you would have had the time
and i think that it's only fair
that we allowed you the time to do this
so and i you know your arguments are all
very good arguments we just have a
different
philosophy on what is what's the right
thing to do with this so
um mickey have we gotten the amendment
yet from
ols no we have not
so an option is you could make a motion
to
you know we saw the language drafted in
another bill
i can just be tasked with making sure
the house bill two amendment is drafted
and you don't have to vote on a number
if you are nearing the end of business
and you want to wrap it up
um that's up to you we've done that in
the past we haven't had to do that this
session because we've had everything
prepared in time but
that's not something we haven't done in
the past um
so okay so
so the motion the motion would be
to ensure the language
from
and the only thing that i'll just point
out is it we would just um tack it on to
the related section in
section 45 in in house bill 2. so
that's another kind of different thing
from that amendment we looked at on
senate bill 135
it was a new section for house bill 2 we
would add it onto an existing
related section same language though
yeah okay so
can we move that the language
from amendment 10
10 to sb-135
certainly and and that'll take care of
it okay
that does it for me i mean i expect to
get the amendment any second now and
then
we'll have it i'll make sure the
committee has it we'll put it online but
you can
kind of preempt that and just take a
motion
um take a vote now allowing us to do
that
okay and then if um if the amendment
comes in while we're
voting we can change our emotion
okay representative murray can you just
give me a you know 12
word refresher of what this is doing
okay my understanding what this is doing
is that it is um
determining the adm a for third grade
pupils at the
school for the school year 2019 and 2020
and putting that into the budget
for um adequate education it's
already there it they just didn't have
authority to do it is that
is that correct mickey yeah the amount
that's in the budget now out of the
governor's office
kind of assumed that the assessments
were going to go forward and and
so this will allow doe to use
adms associated with that third grade
reading component um
yeah it would be advantageous to the
districts and then it'll line up with
what's in the budget now so
there is no budget impact to this mark
was correct and we'll just kind of put
oh okay thank you
i thought i had a motion already but
maybe i didn't okay
so that was uh representative petrie yes
sir
second second thank you
and and you know madam sure before i
call the role can i just ask
am i correct that the amendment number
we're talking about is 10
10 well that's the current amendment
to sb 135
the hb2 amendment will will have a new
amendment
a new number okay all right i'm sorry
yes i understand what you're saying
all right okay um i don't understand
i am ruining my pens one more run out it
ran
out of ink
okay all right uh representative petry
representative peter of ogs all right uh
representative bucca
who goes yes uh representative heath
ethos yes representative
uh murder representative yes
uh lynn votes yes um representative
murray
murray votes yes and uh representative
umber
representative umberger votes yes
the vote of seven to zero in the
affirmative
thank you and um uh
mark i want you to uh
tell the folks in doe they owe us
okay no they owe us big thank you for
that fix
please well you've you know mickey's
hair is turning gray
it's not gonna turn gray either but it
is yeah
it is absolutely okay so
um
is there anything else
to be brought before the division
i have no other change requests
amendments anything
so i think we are um i think we're ready
to wrap up if
if the committee is okay
so oh yes representative heath thank you
ma'am too just one quick question i just
want to make sure
that um the amendment that we voted on
before um
just um trued up the money
come coming into the trust fund and the
money um we're not using
that money from the trust fund to go to
dod
is that correct the yeah the the net
impact of division two's recommendations
at this point is general funds into the
education trust fund
thank you thank you
all right so nothing else if there's
anybody out there
don't call me okay call somebody else
so the um the first motion
is to allow
for the office of the lba assistant
to make technical corrections if needed
to hp1 and hb2 amendments
adopted in order to meet the division's
intent so moved
bob right can forward these to you and
then you don't have to write
write all the words down oh okay
uh sure that's fine i just uh i i just
i'm just making notes so i remember you
know
just so i kind of remember what's what's
happened
um are you ready to call the role
i am yes um
[Music]
uh yes uh so uh representative uh petra
president peter of ots uh representative
bucca
uh buco votes yes representative heath
heath bocces representative murder
representative murder yes lynn votes yes
representative murray very votes yes
and representative humbert
representative umberger votes yes
it's a seven to all vote in the
affirmative to allow uh
uh mr landrigan to as you say true up
the
the uh the language to meet our intent
okay
all right now i've got one other motion
here
and that is for hb1
a motion to accept the governor's
recommended budget
as amended through previously adopted
division changes for the departments of
safety
fish and game transportation
and education as well as
the lottery commission police standards
and training council
university system of new hampshire and
the community college system
of new hampshire okay this is just the
the formal hb1
adoption are there any questions on that
okay seeing none you know
before we go on we haven't talked about
police standards and training
for uh a month and it was just
it was or efficient oh no we did make a
change to fish and game
so it's uh it's just kind of funny to uh
to have that here but we're done okay
um
representative lynn right so you know
can i just can i just
make sure i'm understanding what we're
what you've basically said just said is
we're we're moving to to approve the
governor's budget
subject to all the changes that we've
made
at during the course of our hearings on
the budget
yes yeah and the reason for that is
so we vote on changes right so for
instance
you know all the different line items
positions added here and there
but this is just to confirm everything
we didn't change
is going to remain unchanged from how it
came to us that's really the purpose of
this just to make it clear
sure no no i appreciate that all right
thank you very much for the
clarification
don't move man okay thank you
representative petry
do i have a second
okay all right
when you are ready representative
yes thank you uh representative petrie
petrie ogs uh representative bucco
uh
representative murder representative
murder votes yes
uh rep uh representative murray murray
votes no
[Music]
and representative umber representative
humber
votes yes right it's a vote of four to
three
in the affirmative okay so
um
i know you're voting against the budget
i got it
um no matter what no matter how
how agreeable we were
during the course of our negotiations
over the budget
and hb2 um
i understand okay so uh
there's no no animosity i guess
is what i want to say on my part it's uh
it's
the way it goes so thank you all
uh i i hope
you i'll be right with you
representative heath i hope all of you
have seen the notices from
uh janet i was quite surprised when i
got them this morning but um
monday tuesday and wednesday
at nine o'clock uh
monday we're doing the um
bills that we have retained you know
and as far as i know all of the bills
that were on that list were retained
and then in the afternoon we will start
um the hp1 and hb2
and we'll go until we're finished i
guess
i mean we'll stop sometime on
monday and then start back again at nine
o'clock on
tuesday and then the um
we will be briefing the uh
legislature on march 5th
march 5th on april 5th
at one o'clock okay
and so um and that requirement is that
it needs to be completed
two days prior to when we're going to
vote on the budget and it's my
hb1 and hb2 will be
very early on in the session on the
7th in either first or second
i don't know which but it will be uh
it'll be right up there so
uh that'll be
down in bedford okay so
uh representative heath just i want to
reiterate
my thank yous to you madam chair it has
been
a pleasure and i really feel that
although i couldn't vote um in the
affirmative for this budget i feel that
we have a much better budget coming out
of division two
then it came to us so thank you um
i the whole group worked together so
well and and you afforded us
um a lot of opportunities and i
appreciate that thank you
oh you're you're quite welcome i uh i
i try to make sure that we're
we're all there and oh by the way we get
to
um we get to start again
on the on the senate bills
that will be uh will be coming to us but
uh
we'll see we'll see what that is so uh
representative lynn
oh thank you madam sure i i guess um
what i
just want to make sure i'm clear so next
uh first of all we're not going to be
meeting
tomorrow is that right that's correct
we're done
and then uh starting next week the
monday and tuesday
wednesday of next week that's with the
full
uh finance committee yes correct that's
correct
okay yeah i just wanted to just want to
make sure i had that right all right
thank you okay um
we got the amendment on the um
um
third grade reading uh it's
the same thing but it's amendment uh
so mickey would it be a little cleaner
voted on this or do we need to you can
if you want if you want to just have a
official vote for each number that's
certainly a
reasonable thing to do we can do that if
you want okay i just think it would be
cleaner to make sure that we had all of
our own numbers so
so um do i have to reconsider that other
vote
now no okay i didn't think so
okay uh representative lynn
uh yes okay so i'll call them
yeah i need a motion right i'll make
that motion to uh
put forth uh 20 20 21 10 30
h okay do i have a second
now we're ready okay one second
all right uh representative featuring
uh representative bucca bucco votes yes
uh representative heath ethias
representative murder representative
otius
representative lynn votes yes
representative murray
murray votes yes and uh representative
amber
representative umberger votes yes
all right okay seven to zero
uh in the affirmative okay thank you
um did someone have their hand up before
oh yes
representative murray i just wanted to
add my thanks you were just incredibly
gracious
and very very patient with all of us and
i just want to let you know
we'll have to have a drink sometime and
talk that over but i really really
appreciate
how really gracious you were and your
incredible patience
and i think this was a very enjoyable
committee
um with which to work and i thought you
know we all didn't get where we wanted
to be but
um i think we did basically good work
and
we worked well together so thank you oh
you listen you're you're quite welcome
and as i said we will continue to do
this
as we as we move forward we've got a
what a year and a half or more to
uh to uh to work together
and uh you know even with um
our new members and our substitute
members that we've had
um you know it seems like uh
in the last two weeks we've had
different people every day but i think
it's worked out well
and um i ask that you have a good
rest of the day and i will see
everyone but troy on monday
i had a little more thing now oh yes you
probably won't see me
um that's my second kovitch shot so um
uh
mary is going to arrange a sub for me i
intend to listen in
as much as i can but i obviously won't
be able to participate
but i do want to hear the discussion as
much as i possibly can but i'm going for
covet number two
okay well you know the morning yeah the
morning gate
is all or well however long it takes us
to get through the uh
retain bills yeah if we could do a half
and half sub then you know i would be
down with that but
i don't think that's allowed no that's
not allowed once you
once you sub you're just yourself
yeah as the reporter will be joining us
pardon
my driver will be joining us because
she's familiar with what we've been
doing
right right and uh mickey do you have
too much work to do this weekend
uh actually the goal is gonna try to be
to get a lot of it done before the
weekend i think we're gonna
you know whatever documents that we
prepare for
monday obviously we'd like to get them
at least digitally into the hands of the
committee members as soon as we can so
keep your emails you know open and
um we will be putting everything online
i i'll probably be putting some sort of
summary
just an easy to read summary of what
we've done in division just so everyone
can kind of
um make sense of some of the
reconsiderations we did and some of the
motions that kind of affected previous
amendments you know specifically that
transfer thing i know is tripping some
people up so we'll clarify some things
and um that was a long answer to an easy
question yeah i'll probably be working
vicki you deserve more thanks than i
could ever express
yes absolutely absolutely thank you so
much
yes we uh you know every budget
in division two we have one steady
hand and that's uh that's mickey i don't
i we can't thank him thank him enough
and andrea you have i know that you're
helping nikki
do a lot of things that are well behind
the scenes
but uh it's uh it's it's so good
to meet you and to have you as uh have
you as part of our team
so okay thank you so much the pleasure's
all mine
oh you're quite welcome okay so we'll
see you monday and remember the budget
isn't over
until the committee conference finishes
their work so
there's plenty of opportunities to uh
see what happens so thank you all thank
you mickey have a nice weekend